Well, welcome to part two of our academic
entrepreneurship sessions.
This is my desk.
The first one was chaired by Mike Caligiuri, who
kicked us off with talking about some of the earliest
steps in going from a great idea to
moving your idea along to a product.
And today, this afternoon, I'm sure we'll continue some of that,
and try even to take some questions or give some thoughts
about the "preparing for a perfect landing."
And what we'll do
to start is we will go around the room,
around at this table, and hear from
Levi, Avi, and Christian a little bit about their journey
so you get a sense of how they wound up at this
table and where they are in their careers.
And we'll give each one 5, 10 minutes
to educate all of you
about different pathways
to get into the drug development space in a serious way.
And then after that,
we'll take questions
from the audience, of course, and
I have a couple of questions myself.
So with that, let me begin to my left with
Dr. Levi Garraway.
Thank you, Bill, and thanks everyone for coming in the
Saturday morning to this session.
So,
as Bill said, I'm Levi Garraway. Currently, I'm the chief medical officer, and I
run global product development at Roche and Genentech, but I
started my career in academia in cancer research.
I
was in the Dana-Farber/Harvard system, the Broad Institute,
a really wonderful
journey, and ran a cancer genetics
laboratory, but also was involved in some of the early work
around precision oncology, which was a real privilege to be able to do.
I guess why I'm on this panel, there are a couple of things.
One is when I was in academia, I had the privilege of being able to
co-found two companies. One company is called Foundation
Medicine. It was one of the first companies to leverage the,
at that time, emerging massively parallel sequencing technology to have
a different kind of diagnostic that was able to look at
whole panels as opposed to one gene at a time, and then to figure out a path for
that to be used clinically. And so that company ultimately now is
part of the Roche group, which is kind of fun because we had a reunion.
I'm now a part of Roche as well. And then the other company
is a company called Tango Therapeutics, which was founded on the
idea of synthetic lethality, but also my lab had
published one of the initial papers showing that in the setting of MTAP
deletion, there's a dependence on PRMT5.
And so now, Tango is one of the companies that is developing
PRMT5 inhibitors in the clinic.
But then, I guess because of obviously the science, but
also the fun of being able to see how science
when deployed in the clinical realm can have a significant
impact on patients, that ultimately when there
was an opportunity that came up
initially at Eli Lilly, I was running oncology R&D at Eli Lilly, and now for the
past close to seven years, I've been at Roche Genentech in my current job.
So that's sort of the arc. I'm sure we can, with the audience, talk
about many
factors that maybe in hindsight I would say worked,
or maybe things that should be avoided.
But I'll stop there and let my other colleagues introduce themselves.
Yeah. Avi.
Thank you, Bill, and wonderful to follow Levi and his story.
I have a very similar trajectory, and it's, let me just say, a privilege to be on a
panel like this and learn from my colleagues here.
I'm a pulmonary and critical care physician, Canadian originally.
Been in Boston my entire career. I started my career, like Levi, as an
academic physician scientist. Did that for about 15
years at Boston University Medical Center.
About a quarter of my time there was spent in the critical care unit, which was my
first love, to take care of really sick patients.
And the other three quarters of my time was in the lab, developing genomic
biomarkers for the early detection of lung cancer.
And in 2008, we had our first big aha moment, made a
discovery, had a first potential diagnostic test for lung
cancer, and then I hit the valley of death and became a
serial entrepreneur by necessity, not by design, and made a
lot of mistakes. Back to Levi, I wish I could go back in time.
Started three companies, one of which was a smashing success, leading
to a diagnostic test on the market today for lung cancer.
The other two were definitely not successes, and during the discussion, we can
talk about what worked and what didn't.
But I was very, very fortunate in 2018 that Bill Height came knocking on my
door, and an opportunity at Johnson & Johnson to lead an
R&D group that's bringing together medical technologies
with drugs to transform cancer care, sort of interventional
oncology. And it was too good of an opportunity to turn
down, and especially to go work for Bill Height, who I learned everything about
big pharma from. And it was a startup at J&J. We'll come back to this.
It was sort of an incubated new idea, so I had an affinity for it as
a serial entrepreneur. I've been there now eight years.
I miss Bill Height, who retired a year and a half ago, but it's been an incredible
journey. And for me, the contrast, I'm sure Levi has the same thoughts, between
startups and big pharma, and how do you get over that valley of death,
and as an academic, which route to choose when you do have a promising
innovation. So look forward to the conversation today.
And Christian.
I'm Christian Henrichs. I'm a professor at Rutgers University.
I'm a physician scientist. I'm here, I think, with an academic perspective
as somebody who has been able to, at an academic
level, move research from the lab to the clinic, and now
I'm mostly functioning at that interface where we're trying to go from
that to more of a commercial
application.My
background is different than everyone else's.
I actually initially trained as a general surgeon and a surgical oncologist.
I went to the NCI, where I started doing laboratory research.
I lost an eye while I was in the lab, had to stop operating as a surgeon, and
became a medical oncologist. As a medical oncologist, I started
developing cellular therapies with a focus on treatments for
HPV-associated cancers.
At the NCI, and again, this is in a government role, so very different
than where most of us are,
I started doing clinical trials, and
I had several technologies that the government owns and some that have been
licensed out to companies and developed by companies.
And I discovered some additional technologies where
we did clinical trials that showed good clinical activity and safety, but then
transitioned into a traditional academic environment at Rutgers
Cancer Institute.
Rutgers have built up an infrastructure for being able to
take
treatments from the lab to the clinic, including a GMP facility and an
entire regulatory apparatus for bench-to-bedside and back-again research.
And there we've been able to do proof of principle studies that
have shown clinical activity for a technology out
of my laboratory for the treatment of HPV-associated cancers
and obtain actual evidence in patients, including durable,
complete responses with this approach.
And we're now trying to take that forward to a more
commercial setting, as well as trying to develop new
technologies that
may even supplant the SIMPI Next Generation.
Yeah, let me
open it up for questions. And as we get started, let
me begin actually with you, Christian, because
you're in a very unique
situation where you are
addressing the valley of death with clinical
data for cell therapy. So maybe you
could talk a little bit about, from your perspective within an
academic institution with a product that has been in
patients, where the challenges have been and
what have you learned during the process?
Well, that's a great question, and there's a lot there.
So
one thing that I think that is important to understand
if you're an academic trying to move treatments
from the lab to the clinic is that
it does require substantial infrastructure and know-how at your
institution. Either you need to know how to do it, or you need to have a
mentor who knows how to do it,
or you need
an institution that can
develop these capabilities at a leadership level.
But if you are able to put that together, I think it's very powerful because
it lets you take something from the lab to the clinic and get
that proof of principle without the dilutional challenges that
were discussed in the prior session.
It's a major lift.
It's a little bit hard to know exactly what the key points are, but I
think that one reason why you don't see it done a lot is
because you really have to focus on it, and it covers a lot of
territory. It's not like you
can just farm it out or touch it once or twice.
You really have to be dedicated to the effort.
A couple of other key components to it.
I think it's really important to have institutional support.
And in pulling together the institutional support, it's important to understand
where
the motivations are within the institution and the various components that
contribute to it. So one thing that I found is that
you might think of yourself as a physician or a scientist,
but you really have to understand the institution that you're
at and how it functions and the administrative
mechanisms and relationships and motivations.
And if you can
understand that network and understand
what makes each of those components tick and get
them pushing in the same direction-
Mm-hmm
... you can actually get a lot done and
marshal a lot of resources and get a lot of momentum on your side to
take these things to the clinic.
Yeah. Great. And again, we are open for questions, but I'll continue,
and maybe start with Avi and then Levi.
Again, the same question about crossing the valley of death, but from the
perspective, because we had a question in the first session
in the diagnostic space, and both of you have accomplished it in the
diagnostic space. So in that regard, how did you go about
raising the money? What team did you have to build to get it over the finish
line? Avi, let me start with you.
Yeah, I think it's better to start with me, then go to Levi than the other way
around.
Let me go back to the very beginning of my story.
So I mentioned I'm an academic physician scientist, a pulmonologist.
We have an aha moment in 2007, 2008.
We develop effectively a molecular Pap smear test for lung cancer.
We can brush cells in the trachea, look at the transcriptomic
profile, and decide whether a nodule deep in your lung is malignant or not, based
on a field of cancerization concept.
We're really excited, but we have at our institution, to your point,
not a lot of support in terms of going out and partnering with industry.
So I get really frustrated. We have this great discovery, and yet I go
back to the ICU the next week, and I'm caring for patients who are dying of lung
cancer when we know if we can diagnose this disease early, outcomes will
be transformed. So by necessity, my colleague and I, Dr.
Gerry Brody, go out and try and start a company, and we couldn't even spell the
word company.
Mm-hmm.
And we went out and tried to raise venture capital funding.
I'll just share one story because I'm a humble Canadian, so I'm happy to share with
you the bad stuff. So it took us about a year to even get
a venture capital company to let us in the front door and make a pitch.
We finally get in thereI'll never forget the day, 2010.
I'm super excited. I get 45 minutes.
I put together a deck of 80 slides, 8-0.
Because, but why 80? There were 80 genes in our biomarker.
I had a slide for every gene, literally.
I wanted to tell this VC group how excited I was about each and every gene in this
biomarker, and the importance. Get in the room, and by the way, I'm not going to
mention the name of the VC group in the Boston area, but you can probably guess.
We get in the room. There's seven or eight of them around the table.
I'm five minutes into the pitch in my deck,
and I can tell I've lost the room. They are shifting in their seats.
Back then, they were looking at their BlackBerrys.
Finally, mercifully, the lead investor at the table raises his hand and says, "Dr.
Spira, stop the presentation. I have one simple question
for you to answer. How much money are you looking to raise?"
And I remember looking at my colleague from BU and realizing we hadn't really
thought deeply about it. And
I was much younger back then, so when I didn't know the answer to the question, I
kept quiet, but my colleague didn't, and he gave the famous last
words, which were, "Well, how much money do you have?"
And literally, we were shown the door three minutes
later. They put their arm around me as they ushered me out, but we were in that
room for about eight minutes. We never got to that 45 minute, never to get back
into that room. So we learned. So to your question, Bill, raising money is very
difficult in the startup space, especially
back then. It took us about another year to get the pitch right,
to know your audience, to build a business case.
But even then, we raised a first round of capital from two venture groups
to get two clinical trials to validate a diagnostic biomarker for lung cancer.
And we were haunted by that original question, "How much money are you looking to
raise?" We didn't raise enough. And the only thing harder than raising a
first round of financing is going out to raise a second round when you haven't
completed the goals of the first round. And that's what we had to do.
We raised a B round. It was extremely
painful. We got it done. Two clinical trials published in "The New
England Journal" in 2015, and then we were acquired by a much
larger company called Veracyte in California that commercialized the
test. It's called Percepta. It's in the market today, but
some of the lessons from that is the difficulty in raising money and I think having
a clear intended use population for the test.
That's something that we don't do very well in academia when we have a
discovery, is really narrowing down, especially for a diagnostic, where
it fits, what clinical decision-making is it going to alter, and what type
of evidence do you need, both validation and clinical utility data,
to get reimbursement. So a long journey, a difficult journey, but that
ended well.
But you did have a landing.
We did have a landing. But it was, let me just say, this was
a roller coaster ride, and
I lost a little bit of hair and my telomeres shortened.
But as I said, I'm very gratified. That's the one thing I
did in academia, discovery-wise, that's made its way all the way to the clinic, and
very proud of it. But a lot of lessons on that journey that I would do differently
if I had to do it again.
How about Foundation Medicine? Levi, maybe a little bit of a different
story.
Yeah, a little bit of a... That's a tough act to follow, though.
Actually, I think that's the story worth remembering, actually, because of the
pain of-
Right
... the passage. But maybe I'll just, rather than tell the whole
Foundation Medicine story, I might just call out one
element. I'll pick up on one thing that you said, which is, when one
has an idea, whether it's a therapeutic or a diagnostic, and you're
thinking about pitching the idea, it's often helpful
to understand what is in the mind of the venture capitalist.
What are they looking for with the pitch?
And there's not always one answer, but a common answer
is...
So in the tech sector, there's this phenomenon called the power
law. And the power law basically says that
if you make 10,000 investments,
9,950 will fail completely. You'll lose your money
completely. But there's a subset of investments that are so successful
that they more than make up for all of the failures.
So a venture capitalist might be thinking, "Can this be
a big thing? What
am I investing in, actually? Is this a big thing that could really change the
field? Or is it another
situation of, 'Hey, it's an addition...'" And that might be fine.
If it's de-risk, then that's great.
But that would be a question maybe it's worth asking
yourself. Is my diagnostic or therapeutic idea,
is it a big thing? And why do I believe that?
And if you believe it, that's the story you have to tell, and you have to win their
hearts in the first few minutes. So anyway.
But I bring that up because for Foundation Medicine, we actually did think it was a
big thing. We're not just bringing a new diagnostic test.
If we had gone to various VCs and said, "We have a new
cancer diagnostic test that we want you to fund," again, they probably would've
looked at their BlackBerrys, put their arm around me.
But it's sort of like, this is going to change cancer diagnosis.
This is going to change how it's done.
And it's going to be relevant to all cancers, not just one cancer or a subset of a
cancer. And so it's going to be highly enabling. There's nothing like this.
So it was a different story, and that, I think, maybe
helped us get a little bit more attention.
And of course, it was a great convergence.
Targeted therapy clearly was coming.
There were kinase inhibitors and things in pharma pipelines.
Mast cell paralysis was clearly coming.
So you could paint a picture of the convergence in the moment.
So
one common path is you've got a good idea, and it's going to be painful to
get it there, but you'll get it there. Or not. Maybe it doesn't work.
But then if there's a big thing, don't miss the opportunity to
describe the big thing.
Yeah. I think that point, I want to double down on,
because
in addition to describing when
your product works, not only will it be big, but
remember that the market is moving, and your
product will take some time to get there.
You have to be able to... explain why five,
10 years from now, if it's a drug you're still going to be over this quality
innovation threshold and I think that kind of passion and
belief backed up by data will often gain some traction.
So we have a question. Please.
Oh, yes. Oh, thanks so much for sharing those stories.
So because the Lung Cancer, I
use foundation back in 2013, for my
patients. So how I work, I'm a dermatologist.
I taking care of a rare cancer patient called
mucosal carcinoma. It's very like only 3,000 cases a
year in the United States. So I'm also studying this
rare cancer, so I really, really feel like a
disadvantage when I couldn't even picture myself sitting
and pitching this rare cancer research and
then the drug target that based on
this rare cancer in front of the people that you guys
pitch the idea. So my question is,
so over the years, so I have a very grateful
patient, and husbands,
does support my research. So I know,
because as a physician scientist, we need the grants to give a
protected research time. So I'm always do my research mainly
based on the grants funding. So, I
know at this moment, so my question is that when is the time?
I know he's there, he's waiting for me to ask for money, but
every year he has an annual contribution, but I could have asked
for more. So in this situation, what's you
guys' suggestion when to ask for help?
I'm very fortunate, but I also wants to be very
respectful, when I ask for, and it is something because
the IP is filed, the patent's filed without him involved.
So what would be the, is that fair for him?
So that's, I want to see if
you guys have any suggestions.
Let me make sure that I can rephrase the question slightly.
So there's two parts of it. One is,
as a person with an academic position, you have
split, objectives or responsibilities.
One is you have a grant that you want to keep funded, so you need to work on that.
And the other, you have an idea that could become a product.
And so there's already a conflict of time, let's say.
The other issue that you're facing is one that most people
would love to have, and that is you have a donor who might want to
invest. So your question is, when should you
ask for money? That's kind of an interesting question.
Christian, you've been asking for money from time to time.
When should she ask?
Yeah, I guess I'm thinking about this in terms of, what's the next
step for you? What do you want to do?
That has to be clearly, what are you
asking for? In the
business world, what's the use of proceeds?
But even when you're
thinking about these discussions with a donor
or with your institution, what are you going to do with the money?
So that's kind of the first thing I was thinking about is,
what's your goal? Where you want to get with it?
And then the next thing that I'm thinking about is,
yes, a donor might be able to support this.
It's also, I think, nice if you can put a little bit of distance between yourself
and the ask through your development office.
Nice.
And then the next thing I was thinking about is there are really a lot of
ways to draw on institutional
resources and kind of resources in the
ecosystem of an academic center that go beyond
just putting it all on one source. So philanthropy
or development, that's one, but also, and this goes
to my prior comments about understanding the
institution's motivations, but if it's an
institution that wants to be able to put forward success of
development, of institutional technologies, of
innovation that's gone forward to patients, there may
be sources of funding there that you really have
to understand your institutional's
administrative structures and try to work your network
internally.
Mm-hmm.
Then there are,
as discussed, there are a number of other sources, including
grants.
I would think about what you want to do and then try to
pull together
resources from multiple places so it's not just all being carried at
one point.
I think
building a team around you, you're
facing something that many of us face when we're back in academics.
You have certain responsibilities, let's say teaching your students in the
lab, your postdocs, your grant support,
sometimes clinical responsibilities, and then you have this passion
about something you think could become a product to help patients.
And most of the time,
people find it very difficult to do both successfully.
So many of the times you have to choose which one you want to do well.
Someone will say, "Well, look at Bob Langer at MIT.
He does it all the time." And I would say to them, "Yeah, but you're no Bob
Langer." And very few people are, but it is something.
Livai, to you.
Yeah, actually, so it's an important general question because,
obviously in any environment, but certainly in the current environment
Cultivating additional sources of support is critical.
And actually, big picture, there are some who have argued
that there are individuals across the
country with a lot of capital, and as the baby boomer era
is now sort of well into retirement, there's a broad
consideration of giving in general, and healthcare
is a very common opportunity.
So you're asking specific questions, but it's actually a general
opportunity that maybe is sometimes underappreciated, the amount of
capacity latent in the country there is.
So, and you also have some things that are really important.
You have somebody who has a track record of showing that they are willing to fund.
They care about your project in general, but life sciences in
particular. You have a relationship.
I mean, often for these donors, you can't just go and pitch them like
a VC. You need to actually cultivate relations. So you have a relationship.
And so the opportunity now might
be to... It's the same thing. What is in their mind?
Like, what would that individual really be
motivated to support? And how do you frame
your question in that way? So how do you frame it is, it
might even be you say, "Look, Merckel Cell, this is the kind of thing, there's not
a lot of government funding for it.
Big pharma companies don't tend to," but you
could really change this. And how do you paint that
picture? And I would think more broadly than bringing something,
the next step in... Think big about
what that would look like. What would a program that he could fund, and
several years later look back and say, "This is my legacy"? That's the opportunity.
Yeah. So that really brings us to this issue because we had a lot of questions in
the earlier session, and we're getting to it
today about
alternative
funding opportunities to help at this moment when you're in
the so-called valley of death. This was a grateful
patient.
That's a great one. But there are others that
might be of interest.
So, let me start with you, Avi.
What other
opportunities beyond VCs were you looking for
to try to get this to the next stage of development?
Yeah, I think that's a critical question.
It really ties nicely to the question that was just asked about Merckel Cell and
alternative sources of funding. And I told you in our story, it took us a couple of
years before we could even get the A round done. So what did we do in the interim?
I think there are other places to go. One, we got some institutional support.
So we lobbied the university, and they created something at
Boston University called an Ignition Fund, which is sort of a
$50,000
fund that they give once a year for technology that might be
commercializable to help PIs at the institution to get up
and running. But it wasn't just the money, to be honest.
The $50,000 was trivial. It was the help putting the right
deck together to go out and pitch. So we had students at the School of Management,
the Questrom School at BU, actually sit with us and say, "Hey, what
are you trying to achieve? How much do you need to raise?
How do you put that deck together?" And I would say that, so it isn't just the
money, it's also getting that guidance and moving something forward.
The other place we went that I would sort of throw out there as an idea is
angel funding, and maybe it's related to the donor, but there are high-net-worth
individuals that are not venture capitalists per se, but they
come in and want to provide funding at a very early stage for an idea
to get commercialized where they have a particular affinity for the disease.
And in our case, I'll just say, Robert Craft in Boston, his
wife had died of cancer, first wife, and so he actually was
very interested in getting some angel funding.
So we did take a small amount, but it was really important, and
that helped us when we went to VCs to say, "Hey, you're not the first to
invest. We've had other people along the way." That was a really important piece as
well.
We have a question to our right. Yeah.
Yes. Thank you. I think my question relates a bit to what you just
flagged, not just funding, about the support of
other players within the ecosystem.
And it was mentioned that both infrastructure and know-how are needed to
take something forward and overcome the valley of death, which is becoming
bigger and bigger at the stage that pharma wants clinical stage
assets.
Perhaps if you could comment on
how important is the ecosystem, as they're all different around the US, but
around the world as well, and what type of know-how was
essential for you to sort of get
along that bridge that overtakes the valley of death.
Mm-hmm.
And the second point is how important is the stage of your
career at that level? So if you were in the
early stage of your career, it's probably going to be more difficult if you weren't
established
in that point. So if you can comment on both aspects, which I think is also
important as much as the funding.
Yeah, so that's a very good question.
Because they are both important
considerations.
At what stage of your career
do you want to begin the journey into
entrepreneurship?
And
when you do, how will you be received
by investors or someone who wants to invest in you?
That I think is a very good question.
And the other question that we hear a lot is, well, how do you
make these connections?
To, and to your point, there
are investors all over the world. We tend to
be, at times, US-centric, but great venture
funds exist all over the place. So it's a good question.
So I'd be curious, Levi, do you want to start?
At what stage of your career did you get this bug
into it?
Yeah, it's a great question, actually, and when I
wasStarted the process that ultimately led to being a co-founder
of FMI. I was very early in my career. Very early.
In fact, it was the initial studies were started even before my
faculty position was even formalized.
So I was asking the very same, "Are people actually going to look at me
and give me any money?" And
so I kind of fumbled around and did what I thought was the right
thing to do. I wrote a business plan.
I pulled something off the web and tried to model the business plan around it.
But it became clear that this was just not going to
be the path. I wasn't going to be able to
poke around in the dark and actually make this happen.
So then the question was, who in the ecosystem,
who in the system that I was in would be the
one person who, if I could just get their attention and get them
convinced that this might be a good idea, could help me open doors and make
some introductions to others who could at least get the path started.
And in the Harvard ecosystem, it was Eric Lander
at the Broad Institute. It's like, okay, match with apparel sequence is coming.
We know this. I don't have access to it, but this could be a part.
So I had a meeting with Eric, and meetings with Eric, you had
five minutes. That's sort of how it was.
And so I felt like I have to get this right.
But Eric, thankfully, is a very bright guy, so it actually didn't take five
minutes. It took
30 seconds, and he understood where we were going, and he agreed to be helpful.
But that was the initial thing. So it was there because he knew people.
He had connections in venture capital.
He had connections with others I hadn't even thought about who would be, "We need
to have this conversation." So
I think you really have to work the network.
It's really a lot what Christian was saying.
You have to be willing to network, but also think about who are
the... In any institution, there's probably two or three or four people who
have the right-- They've done it before.
They have the right connections, and can you get their attention to help you open
the doors? But there are many steps in the process.
From there, it was another year and a half to two years before we actually founded
the company. There was a lot of work that had to be done to get it right.
So there's another piece to that. I was going to ask, Levi, today,
could you have written that business plan by asking ChatGPT?
Well,
yes, and I will say that that business plan was not worth the
paper that was printed on. But
yes. But that's true. But that's a good point.
There are elements of what's needed that can be helped by the technology that
we have, but there are also other elements that probably the human
interactions and things are just as important as ever.
It is interesting,
another part of this to think about
is when you do make the connection or when you find
the Eric Lander in your institution,
to be prepared. So the question would be
how much data, what do you need
to be able to take forward to think that you are
partnership-ready, investment-ready?
Avi, do you want to-
Yeah. No, that's a tough question, and let me just double down a little bit what
Levi said on the first question around when to do this in your career, because I
was very early as well, Levi. I think I was four or five years on
faculty, my first big paper in Nature Medicine.
And actually, the worry I had was less about my credibility to go out
and raise, which is real. I just told you about how not credible I was.
That was obvious. The harder thing for me was, was this going to
derail my academic career? How are other academics going to look at me?
Am I quote unquote, "selling out?"
Am I not as pure-
Dark side.
And the dark side. And 20 years ago, this was a real thing.
Probably still today, but really
a big issue for me and my colleague who co-founded the company with me, was much
later in his career. Dr. Jerry Brody was the head of the pulmonary center, so
he was the one who really pushed us to do it.
I don't know that I would have done it on my own because I was very concerned.
It takes a lot of time, it's a lot of time and energy in
those early years to get a company off the ground, and it does take away
time from other academic ventures.
That sort of answers that question.
In terms of when is something investable, to Bill's question, how do you know?
That's a tough... Beauty is in the eye of the beholder.
I will say this, I now sit at J&J and evaluate a lot of new
ideas coming both from academia and biotech.
I would have a number of criteria. I'd be curious to get Christian and Levi, your
thoughts, because I do think this is a very tricky space.
But number one,
is there a clear intended use population, target
population for this, either test or drug, that's going to change,
transform clinical management of a patient?
To me, having a real crisp intended use
population to me is number one. Number two,
I want to make sure that this group has thought through the steps
that are going to be needed to generate the evidence to get this across the goal
line. And Bill, what you like to term the future back.
If that's the end game, that patient unmet need, what are the steps you've got to
do to get there? And are there clear de-risking
experiments that can be done early on so
that there's an exit ramp if it's not working?
If you want someone to invest and come on the journey, they'll come on the journey
with you if they know where the exits are and when to get off. So to me, two.
And then three is the team.
And you asked that, I think, the second part of your question is what do you need?
The know-how you need. On the drug side, obviously, it's CMC, regulatory,
clin development, and you don't have to have it yourself.
You're not going to have it all yourself.
But are you partnering with the right people? Do you have the right consultants?
Are you going out and cobbling together that expertise to have a
credible team that would make this investable?
And then the last thing I'll say is, are you just looking for money, or are you
looking for a partner? And there's a big difference.
I mentioned early on, we were just looking to raise dollars, but in the end, what
we really needed was a partner that would strengthen our clinical
development programAnd so funders, whether they be VC, biotech,
pharma, they're not just providing dollars.
Actually, that's the least important thing they're doing.
They're helping to sharpen your thinking and getting this
across the goal line. So I would keep that in mind as well.
We'll get back to this, but we have a question.
Yeah. If you allow me,
can I share just my experience? Like, present myself.
My name is Zakiabegla Tsondal. I'm CEO and CSO of
TerraNovir, a French company, but we are incorporated in USA.
There is a big
difference between European and French ecosystem and US ecosystem.
So we incorporated last year in 2025.
So my experience is really, I can tell it worse, but
I'm happy because it was haunted about resilience and
convinced about our data. Here we are today at the
ACR. Okay? We are here too for new
innovation, research, and how to treat.
10 years ago,
we think only about monotherapies.
And hopefully today, I'm just happy to know that all are
convinced about combination. And we know
that. How many people is around you?
I'm a breast cancer survivor. I'm a researcher, company
leader, and breast cancer survivor. Today, I did my running.
But when I started, my vision is, why we
still research? Why we still regarding new
targets and new... Because we didn't ask the main
question, is
metastasis treatment the same than primary tumors?
No. So when you deal with investors, they
present you a
junior analyst
who don't know your target, don't know the science, how
to deal with such VCs. And I will finish with that.
I faced what we name the Catch-2022.
Without money, you can't have team,
and if you don't have a team, the VCs cannot come.
So I will finish with that. Resilience, patient, and if you are
convinced, maybe you can succeed, but with difficulties.
Thanks for that. I want to stick to that resilience question
for a second and maybe
ask the panels that maybe starting with Levi, because most of the things that we
do
in the early space don't work.
And it is frustrating.
I think if you look at the success rate of
a new drug entering phase one, the probability of getting it over the
finish line is about 10%. If you go way back to the idea
in the lab, and it's 10% to get that to the clinic.
So the odds are stacked against us, and you mentioned
resilience.
Levi, how do you deal with
failures?
Because we all have them.
Well, first of all, thanks for the background and congratulations.
A lot of good things happening. I think the question
raises a real challenge, as Bill was
saying, where
10 years ago, there was a point in time where the
funding in the biotech sector was really
frothy. So if the idea was good, and
it didn't matter how soon, how close you were to the clinic, but it was a really
good idea, biologically foundational breakthrough
idea or a platform or something, that was good.
You could raise good money around that.
Now, things go in waves anyway, and we
all understand why it's even tighter at the moment.
So again, in the mind of early stage
VCs, there's very much a sense of how long is it going to take
to get to that inflection point where
I know if I have a proof of concept. So,
one thing that's probably useful to think about if one is
dealing with an idea, which could be a really good idea, but
there's a lengthy runway, is to think about, is there a way to parse
it, so that I'm not asking for funding to get all the way to here.
I'm asking for funding to get here, and here is kind of
shorter, and at that point, there's
now... I think you guys were bringing this up as well.
There's the point where can I do another round and can
I show the value in that additional round?
And that's sometimes an easier conversation because
you're right. The reality is the ability to have
patient capital, at least in this day and age, it's harder.
We just have to acknowledge it's harder to raise now.
That may change, but it is what it is.
So therefore, the framing of the opportunity has to
be such that it's compatible with the narrower
aperture or a line of sight, if you will, of a lot of
investors.
Yeah. And along those lines, one of the things that we would
ask for
at J&J, and probably others would do the same, we'd want to be sure
that you did the key de-risking experiment, and that one
we might fund.
Things look good, but there's a key experiment that would really de-risk
the program, and that might not be tens of millions of
dollars. But if it worked, we'd have a commitment to
take it forward. So, Avi, Christian, how do
you deal with resilience?
I think Levi is
exactly right. You've got to break it down into chunks.
And nowadays, not just with big pharma, Bill, I think
with VC as well, they want that killer go, no-go experiment
as soon as possible, because they know what you said, those numbers are staggering,
Bill. Let me just reiterate, one in 10 that are in the clinic.
Right.
I heard one in 250, Bill, that are right.
One in 250-
Yes
... pre-clinically make it all the way. And by the way, we're talking about drugs.
We haven't talked much about devices. Maybe we come back to that.
Device profile is very different, success rates are very different.
But as far as drugs go
Hugely risky. And Levi said it really well earlier, VCs know
that, right? They don't want you to hide the risk.
They want you to tell them how you're going to de-risk it.
Acknowledge the risk and tell them so they can place 100 bets out there and have
a few really be home runs. So to me, that is a key success today in
going out and raising money.
Christian, resilience.
You've shown it. I know.
Yeah, I don't know what to say about resilience.
I think that it's a
kind of an inherent trait that people have and if you're
passionate about it, you don't even feel the
losses. It's a series of failures
with faith that the last step will
be a success instead of a failure.
One
comment I wanted to make is about de-risking.
Nothing de-risks like clinical data.
And one of the very powerful things about being an academic,
there are a lot of things that are not powerful about being an academic, but one of
the
very powerful things about being an academic and being in an academic center is,
there are a lot of resources there.
There are a lot of things that academic centers can do.
You also have an advantage in drug development
from
a regulatory standpoint. My interactions with the FDA as an
academic are
much, much easier than those for anyone at J&J.
That's for sure.
And-
Can you expand on that? How so?
Big companies, Roche, J&J, hordes
of regulatory experts. Why is it-
Armies. Armies.
Yeah, well, armies. Why is it easier as an academic to
interact with the FDA?
So this is speaking as a perspective of as an academic.
I
can talk to these guys.
Many of them were academics.
Much of the FDA culture,
at least historically, has been one of
academics.
They are scientists and people who
think about drug development, and I think that the people at the FDA,
and maybe this comes from my upbringing at the NCI, which
often seated the FDA,
they have the same goal as we do. They want to get effective treatments to
patients. And,
as an academic, you can engage them in what
is a relatively low stakes as compared to a
industry interaction discussion.
And you can sometimes
institute clinical trial designs that
you would be told were not possible.
I think
there's a little more leeway when a young company
or an academic goes to the front of the FDA.
They probably want to reach out even more because they're generally very
helpful.
Yeah.
They want to reach out even more. We have a question.
I love science. I love being an academic.
I love actually chasing the research and science.
However, I've recently started thinking about going to the dark side,
which also is tempting.
Do VCs invest on the science and the scientist
regarding whatever drug you've come up with, or do they
invest on a person that's going to take it
entrepreneurially to market? What kind of
individual are you looking for? Are they
looking on the actual scientist, or is this the guy to
take this forward?
Hmm.
So the question is, are the VCs-
Science
... looking at the
person,
or looking at the science? And I
know what the answer will be, but I'll turn it over to our panel. Levi, go ahead.
Yeah, the answer is yes, right?
No, but it also depends.
So the VCs are going to, at any given point,
they've raised a fund, and now they have a wide range of ideas that they're
trying to work up. And some of them are very early, and then some of them are
maybe
later on. And so
what I've seen is that very often they will talk to a lot of people, and they're
having a conversation. They may not even know in their mind what they're trying to
solve for. They just want to see, hey, who is this person?
Are they great? Do they bring the credibility?
Do they bring understanding? And then it might be like, "Hey, we've got this
stealthy thing that we're kind of working up.
Do you want to meet somebody?" So
very often, the entry point, there's not already a specific
type or kind of person. They're just trying to see, hey, is this the kind of person
who might fit well and bring something to this ecosystem that we're putting
together?
Hmm.
I agree, it's definitely a yes to that question, but I would sort of frame it a
little differently and say the innovation, the science is what gets you
into the front door with VC. The person and the team is
what closes that door and gets the deal done.
And by that, I mean you got to be coachable.
You got to be someone that the VC feel is going to receive feedback,
is going to listen, and again, not just looking for their dollars, but looking for
their guidance. And obviously, track record is a big...
I know, Levi, you know this. And that's tough when you're starting your first
company, but I remember very often that they were looking for folks that have done
this before, have a track record of success.
That's often a very good predictor of continued success.
But as I said, it starts with the science and innovation.
There's a lot of it out there, but that gets you in the front door.
And then I think you do close it with the team, the coachability, and the
resilience, knowing this is someone that's going to persist because things happen
that are always unexpected. The VC know it.
It's never going to go according to plan.
Is this the individual on the team that is going to be able to weave and get
through that challenge? And I think they look at that to close the deal.
Christian. Yeah, Christian, well, actually, you raised something.
Go ahead, answer that part, but also when did you decide, and when
should an entrepreneur who's working on a project
begin to
wisely interact with the FDA?
So I'll try to address that.
You can see, of course, my perspective is
as an academic, and I try to think about how far can I
develop this in an academic environment before it
goes to
a situation where you have a
company that needs substantial funding or if you
form a company, how far can you get with your academic data to
be able to leverage that for your raise.
And so,
in terms of approaching the FDA, I've seen two strategies
used.
One is a traditional Pre-IND meeting, which
can be quite productive. The other, and I think, again, this is an advantage
of being an academic, is if you're at a savvy institution and working with
savvy people, sometimes you just propose
it.
Just
file that IND.
Does everyone
understand the terminology?
Investigational new drug is what
Christian is talking about, and there's a couple of steps in that, right?
So there's the Pre-IND space, where you begin the discussion with the
FDA.
Would you want to talk, any guys want to talk-
I'm sorry, I'll back up a little bit and provide a little bit more background,
Bill. So,
if you want to take your drug from the lab to the clinic,
you're going to need to file some important
regulatory
permissions with the FDA.
One is around the drug itself, and there are three main modules you're going
to have to worry about. One is data that
shows that your drug is safe.
Another is to show that you can manufacture your drug.
And another is your clinical trial plan.
And so this goes back to what I was saying before about you need some institutional
knowledge to be able to do these sorts of things.
But before you file your IND that has those and other
components in it, you can meet with the FDA and talk about what you
plan to do. That's a Pre-IND meeting.
There's a decision that's a major forking point,
which is should I have a Pre-IND meeting or should I just file an IND?
And I think there's a lot of traditional advice that would say have a
Pre-IND meeting.
I think it depends on the environment you're in and how much
experience you and those who are mentoring and part of your
team have. But another very viable
and surprisingly successful approach is to just put together a good
IND that you think you can defend and file it.
It's interesting because this actually puts the pressure on the FDA because they
have 30 days to tell you not to proceed after you file that
IND, or you can proceed.
Mm.
And often what you'll find,
again as my experience as an academic, is that about five days,
depending on if there's a weekend or a holiday before that IND
30-day clock ends, you'll get some kind of communication from
the FDA. And my general impression is that they don't want to put you on hold.
They actually are trying to
move things forward. And so part of the strategy, if you just file
a well-thought-out IND in the first place, is that then
you can end up with some questions that you can answer, or you can
also ask for a meeting with the review team and the division director.
But often you can smooth these things out at the last minute
and just do it.
Yeah, the alternative, of course, for a biotech startup, in particular,
without a lot of experience or a team around you,
take advantage of the Pre-IND meeting to get to know the regulators
and get to hear their feedback early on.
That might be something. So I'm curious, Avi and Levi, at
what point did you go to the FDA with your ideas
to talk to them?
Well,
actually for Foundation Medicine, at the time, we
actually took the radical path of going to the FDA because at
the time, you could develop laboratory diagnostic tests
and kind of set up shop and do profiling, et
cetera. Hypothetically, that would've been a path, but we sort of felt like at the
time that there would be a benefit of actually having an FDA-approved path that was
part of that. But
these are also the kinds of things where
building a network of people who can, when you get to that point,
walk you through because there are any entrepreneurial idea that you have,
this is one, but there are going to be a couple of dozen
other areas that you won't know anything about, and you just need the network.
And by the way, the one last point I'll make, because it looks like there's a
question, is the regulatory documentation.
This is one area where generative AI can be transformative.
It really can take you from weeks and weeks of kind of fumbling
through how to put a documentation together to
at least a rough draft very soon. So that's something that
is hopeful for the future.
Interesting. Please, go ahead.
Thanks to the panel for
sharing your experiences with us.
Quick question for you guys as sort of a two-parter.
How do you balance sort of that
going to a VC and saying, "Hey, look,
I'm looking for a partner versus money," but at the same time coming in and
not looking like, "Well, I don't know what the hell I'm doing," right?
Mm-hmm.
I know what I want, but I also know that there's holes in my experiences coming
from an academic background.
And so we've been struggling with trying to
Come confidently to them, but then also asking for their advice.
And then so a good example of that would be, thanks to many of the people in this
room, we have a lot of good therapies for cancer nowadays.
So if I'm coming to you and I'm saying, "Hey, I don't really know," to Avi's point
before, "maybe what my specific target should be.
I've got a MEK inhibitor that I'm trying to layer on top of a
KRSG 12C or something that's going to make immunotherapy
better." Do I need to come to them with monotherapy that
works? Or can I go to them and say, "Because we've done this," and we get a
different answer every time. So I'm curious to see what you guys think.
Well, I think the idea of going and saying, "I don't know what I'm doing," would be
a bad idea. So there's another way of phrasing it.
So
actually, so Levi, what are the things that a company should have
under their belt, the pre-clinical features that perhaps would
be important not just for regulators, but for investors?
Yeah, actually, maybe I'll take it up a level because,
and again, this might sound like a broken record, but if you put yourself in the
position of the venture capital person that you're talking to,
chances are
they have seen a lot of examples of...
The idea that you have might not be the first time they've seen a concept like
that. So this probably gets back to where
if it's possible to have a network of folks that you can sort of talk
to before the kind of big pitch and say, "Hey, is this likely to get shot out of
the sky? Or is this the kind of thing that oh yeah, they see
10 of these a week?"
Because that
process can really help vet your own thing.
Because again, coming back to this power law, let's face it, most of these
ideas, we might love them, but they may not go anywhere.
So the more that you can get a sense, "Hey, what bin am I likely to be
in? And if I'm possibly in the exciting bin, how do I refine
that?" I would probably start there.
And then with that help, now you know how to have the conversation and
pitch, and potentially there's even some back chat.
These networks are really important.
The relationships, and usually word of mouth in VC is
really important. So working those kind of channels before you have the meeting can
be really helpful.
I think
also the same with the regulators.
They have heard
many, many companies come in and probably grappling
with similar questions that you might have.
So I think you
come in with a
target, with some ideas.
And the advantage of perhaps meeting with them early,
is that they can give you guidance.
And that can often be very, very helpful.
Yeah, let me just add, because I agree fully with Levi's comments.
They've seen this before. I think just having the humility, what you know and what
you don't know. They'll recognize what your gaps are.
If you try to pretend something you're not, that's not going to work.
If you do what I did, and show you have no competence at all, that isn't going to
work either. I think it's saying, "Here's what I bring to the table as a founder.
Here are the areas I can provide value to you as a VC.
But hey, I'm coachable. I know there are gaps, and I want you as a partner
because you're going to help fill some of those gaps." And let me add, there's
certain different kinds of VC.
It's not a homogeneous group. There are venture groups within companies like
J&J, a lot of now have these strategic venture arms
that actually have a lot of expertise, and I mentioned the company I had
success with. I had two other companies that were not successful, but one of them
was a pharmaceutical company I founded for COPD, a disease in
desperate need 20 years ago, and still today, of a new therapy.
And we had discovered a new molecule in my lab, and we actually got
funding from JJDC. And it wasn't the money again, it was their
expertise, because we knew nothing about drug development.
I was in the diagnostic space, and we acknowledged that up front,
and that's why they were the right partner for us.
So it's also, as you look at different VCs, who are the right partner?
Who are going to bring the things that you are missing to make you successful?
Yeah, and I think the
other thing is,
early on,
beginning to think about the team that you want to build and who is
going to help you the most,
in the different stages.
We talked earlier in the last session about some universities have some of the
components, but many universities don't.
So,
Christian, you came from the NCI, and
what kind of support and what kind of team
did you begin to build as you began to develop your
ideas?
So that's a great question, and
it's been a new experience for me
doing this and figuring out how to do it.
The team that I'm working with comes from
my university.
We
have formal support from
a former high-ranking
official at the university who has been very effective at
navigating the pathways and the relationships within the
university. And even, in fact, was instrumental
in helping us secure
really quite substantial funding to
secure IP and do some important initial
maneuvers.
The other thing that's been critical
is a combination of good mentoring and mentors
who have actually participated and helped
the company and helped with the team and the team formation.
And this is important just in terms of the
leadership of the company, but then it also becomes really important
when you interact with VCs or potential
funders or potential strategic partners in
theWe go with a whole team of really
experienced people spanning the university
and people who've mentored me and are participating in the
company.
That's important. So Levi, Avi, what kind of
team-- Who was on the team initially, and
what's important in building these teams?
Yeah, I think actually one point that Avi made, which is really important, is
the humility of, like when you think
about going and pitching a VC or a funder for money,
if you go by yourself, the
VCs often, they really respect if they look and the
CVs of, if there's like three or four people, and not
every last CV has to be amazing, but if two or three are great and then there's
you,
because that was me at one point. That's also good because now it's like, hey, this
is a group of people and there's some really highly regarded people here, and
they're basically essentially putting their word
behind this idea. That actually has the effect of
elevating the attention, the likelihood of attention.
And I bring that up because the other dynamic that can sometimes happen, it's human
nature, is like you start, "Oh, well, I don't want to share because it was my
idea, not his" and you know. But, in the end, if it's a good
idea,
the whole money and the economics, that will all sort itself
out. One doesn't have to be overly-- You don't want to be naive, but the most
important thing is who are the people that I could bring
together that will demonstrate the credibility,
the set of skills, and the
clout that a VC would say, "You know what?
This
group of people, even if the specific hypothesis doesn't
transfer, they're going to figure out how to be successful."
So the importance of a team, but then the humility to say, I need to be willing
to not be greedy and selfish, but sort of share that
because it's more important to get the thing out there than
it is to sort of do my own personal mathematical calculus and then-
And Avi, you had a very interesting experience because you went
to the VCs with a world-renowned
clinical person who would not have had the kind of
experience-
That's right
... to go in front of a VC. So I'm curious about the team, but also
how
does
a young entrepreneur
set expectations for the value of what
they're bringing to the VC?
Because
if they ask,
they're going to
make you an offer about a deal,
and if your expectations are far apart.
Yeah.
Experience I had, I thought I had a great opportunity.
I think I asked for millions of dollars for a preclinical idea, and they
said, "Well, we'll give you $10,000 to get started," or something like that.
So you
have to have a pretty good understanding of
how VCs or biotech or pharma
puts value on
an asset at different stages of development. So Avi.
Yeah, that's a critical and very difficult question.
If you all watch "Shark Tank," right? That's often where things fall flat, right?
Is the valuation's way off, too far apart.
Let me just say from my experience, obviously, all the money that this VC had was
not the correct valuation- ... in retrospect.
But I do think there are ways to get there, Bill, and if I could go back in
time and do it differently, and again, I've had two other companies since, and now
in my role at JJ, I'm on the other side of the fence.
What I think founders and academics can do is find
consultants. Find, Bill, folks like you that have been in industry,
who are out there as consultants to guide young entrepreneurs
in being able to bring the right group together to provide that valuation.
And valuation is subjective, and we all think our baby is the cutest and it's going
to be worth the most. Trust me. We all go through that.
So have a dose of realism. And by the way, commercial
assessments are complex. I'm still learning how to do it, how to model adoption and
reimbursement, let alone for drug, also for devices.
Extremely complex. It's almost like going to medical school just for that.
And so bringing the right people together to help guide you
so that you have a realistic range at least to go into those
negotiation with is absolutely critical.
And just back to the question on team,
I love what Levi said. It is having that humility that you got-- And by
the way, just showing that you can bring a team together.
Mm.
That you can develop followership and build a matrixed org.
That's all of drug development, all device. It's a team sport.
A lot of folks who are involved are not directly reporting to you or paid by you.
Can you influence and generate that followership in a matrixed setting?
I think VCs are looking for that.
Mm. Excellent.
Question.
Yes. Hi. I was wondering if you have any advice or
comments on choosing a CRO for safety
study and also for de-risking the technology in the view of
the FDA, but also
VCs.
Mm.
And also in the context maybe of limited funding for biotechs.
Who wants to take it?
I'm happy I could tell you another horror story there.
If you're willing to indulge me. No.
Again, I had a startup in the pharmaceutical space.
We were moving into early phase trials with an inhaled therapeutic for
COPD, and you just don't have the bandwidth to run a trial on your own.
That's the reality, is you're going to have to go out and get a CRO.
What I learned there is do your homework. Get the right CRO.
We didn't, quite frankly, and that was one of the reasons this drug did not
progress beyond the initial phases of development. There were other reasons.
I don't want to put it solely on that, but it's a very difficult thing.
There's a lot of CROs out there. Listen, big companies like JJ also work with
CROs, just to be very clear. But we make the choice when we do, and
often we don't. We have the wherewithal to carry studies on our own.
Startups are not in that position.
So, doing your homeworkTalking to folks in
pharma that work with a lot of CROs, getting the right references and the right
groups to work with is absolutely essential.
Yeah. And I think to that point, this is where you
really need advice, people who have worked with CROs, because it
can be tricky. The contracts can be tricky.
The change orders, which are inevitable, can be tricky.
So you have to select very, very carefully, and you need some
really sound advice. Levi, did you want to say?
No, I think that's-
Yeah, good. We have a question over here, and then over here.
She was first.
Yeah, but she's a chronic questioner. We'll go to you first.
It's her prerogative.
I'm extraordinarily grateful to you all. This has been really helpful so far.
I'm very
junior, so excuse my ignorance, but when you found-
We envy you. What are you talking about?
We all want to be you.
Thank you. But,
so when you founded FMI or when you founded your, I think Percepta was the-
Yeah. Well, the company's called Allegro Diagnostics.
The product was called Percepta.
Was the intent at that point to just develop the product or
to move it all the way to commercialization?
I know both
your products were acquired by much larger diagnostic companies, and then that
allowed it to be, I think, rapidly and broadly commercialized.
Thank you.
Go ahead.
Yeah, for us, the explicit objective was to move to
commercialization because we knew that you could do the approach in
academia. That was happening already.
But it felt like there was
a major gap between the broad utility and what academics
could ever supply. So it was clearly a commercialization play, but
then to your point, it became also clear that the types
of capabilities and skills that were needed were vastly outside, certainly my
experience, and a lot of the experience even of the other founders.
But you're raising an important point.
You have to know what are you solving for, and then that
determines the team and the types of people that you talk to.
But yes, we were all about commercialization from the start.
That should be the goal, right?
Right.
You really want to do everything you can
to ensure that your partners
that you might be contracting with are also thinking about getting
your product to commercialization.
And although you never can get a firm commitment, you get a sense that it aligns
with where they are, and they want to get it over the finish line.
Yeah, no. Like Levi said, it's critical to have that end in mind.
And for us, in Allegro Diagnostics, we wanted to
help shepherd the clinical trial, do the clinical validation studies.
But we knew we didn't have the expertise to commercialize a
diagnostic. Diagnostics are very tricky.
Unlike drugs, reimbursement and economic models, way outside of
my lane, way outside of the lane of all the founders here.
So we knew upfront. In fact, that's what we pitched to the VC that ultimately
funded us, that our goal was to be acquired by a larger diagnostic company that
knows how to go out and get reimbursement and commercialize a product.
Yes.
Sorry if my question take too much of the time.
So just follow up with the team member.
So let's say that so the team member
you're talking about, so they are not involved in the initial
patent filing.
Because then if I need to form a team,
so would they be able to add as a co-inventor
or something like that to the IP? So just want to
clarify.
Yeah. Go ahead.
I would say the patent is an important part of having a path, but it's
not the sum total of the path. If
it is about a team that's going to help found a company, there are many
critical capabilities to make a company from the point of being founded
to get to that next stage and the next stage.
And many times, there's a team member that brings
something critical to that. So yes, they weren't an inventor, but often
the thing that you patent is not the thing that ultimately makes it anyway.
So it really becomes about what are the capabilities and
just expertise that is needed to get this thing off the ground.
And
VCs will also,
oftentimes or sometimes,
provide you with an entrepreneur in residence, someone who will
guide you,
the scientist, through all the hurdles.
I think Third Rock has been particularly good at this in putting really
credible entrepreneurs in residence
onto
an investment to really help the originator
who really hadn't had the experience of being a serial entrepreneur.
Just one thing to add, Bill, to that.
It's less
about the intellectual property at that stage.
It is more, just to put it on the table, how much equity you're willing to give up
from the startup to bring on that team.
That's effectively the negotiation that goes on as you start cobbling that
team. It's a lottery ticket, and people want to know how much of that are they
going to get. That's a tough call.
Yeah.
Come to the microphone so they can hear.
Just to be careful. It's really important.
If this person is not right inventor, you cannot do it because there
is a regulation about the patent.
Of course.
For your patent, you have to add the real inventors.
It's not pleasure to make people if he is not an inventor.
That's it. Not about the-
You cannot put it.
Yeah, no. This is not about the patent. This is about who's the team.
Right.
And not everybody on the team is going to be on the patent.
Correct.
So if the patent was invented at 30% by this or
20% and 50 by this, this does not automatically transfer
to the
company, right?
Could you start the question all over again so we can fully understand?
Yeah. So basically, on the same line because I'm sorry.
So, we have a drug that we
just got a patent, right? So the people, like five
people are involved in that. One chemist, one medical oncologist.
But everybody expected them to
... be to hold the similar shares according to the contribution of
the patent-
Yeah
... in the new company.
No.
So obviously, this is the dumbest question.
After this, everybody should feel better.
So-
No, and the short answer is no. There is no correlation necessarily
between-
No
... percent on a patent and then the percent ownership of a startup.
Yeah.
Startups sometimes license the intellectual property from the university.
Mm-hmm.
University may get a piece of equity for that, but it's not related to the
percentage of the different interests.
Okay, thanks.
Answer.
Question to our left.
Yeah. So Levi's company, Foundation Medicine, seems to
provide a scalable platform, right, for all the
diseases. So it's very different from Avram's company,
specific product for specific diseases and so on.
So should we adopt a very different mentality for thinking
about building these two types of companies?
Well, certainly,
you will know, is what I'm
proposing, is it a platform type company or is it a
either likely single asset or single diagnostic?
There are paths for each. There are very successful paths for each.
But you then know what that is. And no matter what,
though, you have to be able to tell a story about why this is...
I think you said it right. What is the unmet need that this
is going to solve? Why is this the solution for that, and why is
this on pretty much a clear path, or, not easy,
but by funding it, there's actually a
trajectory to success that can be articulated.
Those are true no matter what, but there are important differences about a
platform versus a single asset or single diagnostic.
I think there's going to be a case study, probably at the Harvard Business School
someday, about Grail. So think about Grail for a second.
Huge idea. We're going to go out and be able to tell everyone
what cancer they're going to get and get it so early that it's never going to
bother them. It was a phenomenal idea, such a powerful idea.
They raised an enormous amount of money, enormous amount of money, and
they attract remarkable people to develop the
company.
And as the data became...
And a tremendous team of scientists
and tremendous help from Intuitive, who
was helping along the way with supplying reagents.
And then the data became available.
And as the data became in,
it became clear, at least to me, it was under the board,
that the test was fantastic for a few
cancers.
But as you went down the list, it got less and less
fantastic.
So there, a decision had to be made.
Are you going to be very specific
and scale back your expectations and maybe
provide something for only one or two
malignancies? Or are you going to continue with this big idea
and go ahead and have a pan-cancer screening?
So
you have a great idea, of course, big idea.
But as the data comes in, you may not have
to stay completely in love with your idea,
because the data are the data. And
that's going to guide whether you're very broadly based or
not. And I think Grail, a phenomenal
company. Every aspect of it
will be a very interesting case study someday, I think.
Please.
Thank you for all your insights. I think they're fantastic.
My name's Heather Schwaebel. I'm with Alloy Therapeutics, and I focus on
partnerships. So the one thing I just wanted to say to the group is,
you are always partnering. Every conversation you have from the time you're an
undergrad, before you're a postdoc, when you have the idea, you're already
partnering and networking. And so I just really agree very strongly with the
networking aspect of this because you're basically marketing yourself from the very
beginning. And
networking as giving to others and being generous is where it comes
back to you. But my question is actually about alternate paths to
bringing ideas forward. We see a lot of work happening now with groups like,
a little bit in our venture studio, but the rise of the venture studio in general,
the rise of things like flagship pioneering, where you combine
assets and capabilities with EIRs and funding.
And so we're talking monolithically a little bit about pharma and venture.
But I was wondering if you could talk a little bit about some of the alternate
paths to company formation that are becoming a little bit more prevalent these
days.
Maybe you can tell us a little bit about your studio.
Sure. So Alloy is an eight-year-old company with foundational
platform technology. We also have
services where I describe it as boutique, artisanal CRO services.
And we also have a venture studio that is a funded mechanism where we seed
investments. Sometimes we combine initiatives where we have someone
that comes in that wants to do some work out of academia.
It could be the killer experiment. It could be to get to composition of matter.
It could be to humanize what otherwise looks good as a murine antibody.
We can fund it, and we can wrap capabilities around it to help the
investigator actually launch that company.
I think there's more and more groups out there doing this, perhaps not completely
the same way that we are.
But I was curious to hear where you think that plays in some of this.
Yeah. Anyone want to take it? I know of one. Go ahead, Levi.
I'll start. It's great that you brought that up.
And this is also, by the way,
networking is critically important to learn about these things.
But actually, the world of generative AI can also help
because we can throw out some things that we know, but that'll probably be a
fractional proportion. But in addition to what you mentioned,
there are companies like Deerfield that have veryVery early
stage, they have a number of academic partnerships where there's seed
funding mechanisms. There's, of course, CurioBio, which has a very
democratized approach to founders and pre-money evaluation, and there's a
process there.
And then also, you mentioned that there are funds that will
take something here, something there, something there, and kind of create roll-up,
and this is happening more and more.
Actually, one sees this increasingly in China.
So this is another kind of mechanism that's beginning to happen.
So,
it's the importance of resilience and getting
used to rejection, and
these are all critically important.
But it's also important to gather information about these
kinds of directions because there are more and more of them.
These things didn't exist 10, 15 years ago.
Right.
Exactly.
Avi and-
Yeah, no, I think these are great models, as you said. They're newer.
I wish we had them 15, 20 years ago when I was starting up my three companies.
And I think the idea as an academic entrepreneur is you don't always have to start
the company yourself. There are groups out there, VCs, like Flagship,
that will start companies, take your idea, cobble it together.
I think particularly in these devices, it's particularly hard to start device
companies. Let me just tell you, it's hard to go out and raise VC because the
return on investment is much more challenging.
So I think these kinds of newer models of startups through VCs,
and especially in the device space, are going to become increasingly important.
Absolutely. A former colleague of
Avi and I's named Michal Preminger, is very much involved in this idea
where someone with an enormously exciting
idea needs to crowdsource it with a group
of interested people, and they bring them together almost like in
a boot camp, which you also have,
to ideate and to work on this idea
until they get to the point where they're actually ready to
perhaps go out and fund it and get started.
So I think there are multiple ways of getting at
this.
And thanks for bringing it up. Yeah, please.
Hi, yeah. I'm Alex. I walked in a little late.
I'm not sure if it's already been addressed, but I guess my
question is, so I'm
in academia, and I'm looking for kind of companies to
work with. Oftentimes I walk around during the exhibit hall.
I don't get very far usually, but I guess,
are there any resources that you guys are aware of for
finding companies to work with or ideas or suggestions?
So that's a really interesting question.
So,
there are
ecosystems like Boston, Cambridge, like South San
Francisco, other places,
Shanghai,
Cambridge, Oxford, where there are big
ecosystems of many, many
biotech companies, many startups, and big pharmaceutical
companies have sites there. And
people who are in that ecosystem often
find themselves in the situation where their startup that they're
working for didn't succeed, but it wasn't that difficult
because of the networking that they have in those phenomenal
ecosystems
to find the next opportunity. So I think those ecosystems work very,
very well
as one
idea that I would come up with, and
some are stronger than others.
But that's just one thought. But how about you all?
I think as academics, it's often difficult to collide with the right
companies to take a new idea and partner with.
So I think with the types of conferences you go to, and in particular as academics,
getting out of our comfort zone and going to some of the conferences that you're
going to have a higher likelihood of bumping into the right company.
So BIO is an example. As an academic, I never went.
Now as someone in J&J, I'd go. I look back and say as an academic, maybe
that would've been a good meeting to go to to run into the right people and learn
more about what types of partnership opportunities. I don't want to say J.P.
Morgan, because that meeting is a whole different story, right, Bill?
We don't want to go there. But I just want to give Bill credit.
AACR is now starting to do this, right?
Bill, there's that pre-meeting now.
Yeah.
Trying to create a place for oncology companies to
come and talk to academic entrepreneurs and have that exchange.
Because you need the right amount of collisions to get these results, and it's
difficult to create that ecosystem everywhere.
Yeah. So yeah, Mike Caligiuri and I had this idea that
we would create a J.P. Morgan-like meeting but a subspecialty
meeting, for oncology.
And we start a day and a half before the
general ACR meeting where we bring together the buyers and the
sellers and the academic people who are interested in learning more.
It's called the ACR Oncology Industry Partnering Meeting.
And
this year we had over 600 attendees, which was really
terrific. And it's great for networking, and
not only
for the people who are in the industry or in biotechs, but for
someone perhaps like in your situation, where you might get a sense of,
well, this company might be really interesting, this biotech.
Something that I could bring my skill set to.
So that would be a really good one, I would think.
Thank you very much.
Yeah.
I just want to make one point about-
Yeah
...
academic and entrepreneurial type forces when you're an
academic. They're not necessarily always at tension.
And there can be
cooperation and
movement in the same direction, and that I think it's very helpful
if you're doing high impact science and you're publishing it and you're
presenting it at meetings.
People sometimes even come to you.
Yeah.
And so,
networking
Getting your research out there, this helps your career
as an academic, but it also puts momentum behind
your entrepreneurial effort.
So let me
finish up by just throwing out a general question to the panel.
AI uber alles. So we've done a big review,
Levi was involved with it at ACR,
on areas that will drive the progress against cancer.
And what came out number one on the methodology side
was the power of artificial intelligence machine learning.
And we see it now in
almost every presentation. Someone is remiss if they don't mention something
about AI.
So
I wonder, go from Christian back from your
work on cell therapy,
from where you began and where you are today,
where do you see, where do you envision the role of AI
as we
don't have to look into the future, we are in the future?
I know. It's a new world.
As Yogi Berra once said, "The future ain't what it used to be." Yeah, go ahead.
It's a new world, and as an academic,
and as an entrepreneur, it spans everything that I do.
It's transforming my laboratory.
It's putting more informatics into every
aspect of what we do and making it much more feasible to do that.
I think we all know from a
practical standpoint, there's a lot
of knowledge that you can pull from widely available AI
sources in terms of understanding
drug development pathways, regulatory pathways, putting
together
regulatory documents,
clinical trial protocols.
It has fully infiltrated
my life-
It's a new world
... I can tell you that.
Yeah. Avi, from big pharma perspective.
From big pharma, let me just say, every time now I go into the executive committee
at J&J to pitch any idea, the only question I know I'm going to
get, "How are you going to use AI for this?" I don't know what other
question I'm going to get, but that question is almost certainly to come.
So it's absolutely now ubiquitous. Be curious to get Levi's thoughts.
My impressions right now, and this is what I've told Joaquin and the executives at
J&J, there's places where AI clearly is demonstrating advantages, in
regulatory documents, operational efficiencies.
Where I think there's still a lot of uncertainty is around discovery of
new targets,
developing new drugs against a target that's previously undruggable.
There are a handful of examples out there.
I think it's too early to know.
But obviously you're seeing more and more partnerships between big pharma
and tech companies.
This is clearly the direction of travel. I'm excited about it.
I think there's a very promising future.
But not a done deal, and it's still early, early innings in that game.
Mm-hmm. Levi?
Yeah. Good thing you saved this topic to the very end because it's so easy we can-
But
yeah, there's no question that when you think about the entire R&D
continuum, I can't think of a segment that's not being affected,
and sometimes profoundly, by AI. And so that's
very true. But maybe the distillation is
to the extent that AI can
accomplish things in a much
faster, more efficient way than the human brain can, that's where we need to use
it. But where I sit, the human brain is not
passe. And actually, especially when it comes to drug
discovery, really understanding whether or not the
biology is rich and therapeutically tractable, and there's
just a dimensionality about getting that right that you need humans for.
So I think the people who can master AI and
master the data and the insights that that brings are going to
be sitting pretty. But I don't see it replacing-
See a master
... humans in the discovery process.
Well, listen, I want to thank the panel and the audience
for a terrific discussion. Greatly appreciated.
Christian, very nice seeing you again.
We'll see you on the vineyard.
Absolutely. Mark.
It's great to sit on a panel, weren't they?
Yeah.